no surprise yellen Ryland from from the
sense absolutely and you know with the
list like this there probably aren't
going to be that many surprises because
by definition if they're influential we
probably have heard about them yeah so
no surprise there for that the Chinese
premiers pretty much so things that easy
well slow down or no slow down it
doesn't really matter he still matters
so he comes in number two behind Janet
Yellen um if you were taking a long view
of the world at longview economics Chris
I word would Yellin hit right at the top
are you all most influential is she the
person pulling the strings if she's not
at the top she'd be very close I mean to
me it almost all roads almost always
lead to the Fed these days yeah so even
when you talk about emerging markets all
you're talking about you know that the
state of the world's financial markets
the Fed is front and center so I think
she's always got to be there whoever's
in charge in the Fed top one two or
three for sure yeah and then Tim Cook I
said well here's you know he doubled
apples profits yeah doubled apples
revenue since Steve Jobs so he's thought
to have been doing a pretty decent job
does that does that surprise you a
little I know he's doing a decent job
and I know he's but in terms of you look
at the look at the kind of who's
disrupting the world right now if you
look at kind of how the world is
changing Apple actually hasn't generated
many new products over the last few
years now yes it's influential yes it
dominates in terms of its sales and look
at what happened with the iphone 6 and
success and the sales there but but is
it is it influencing well yes it is I
mean it's influencing it look at its
competitors look at them trying to
trying to catch up it you could I mean
you can make arguments that one of the
one of the fun things about putting this
list together is that nobody agrees no
no I'm sure and you end up you end up
with a list that's basically we start we
start with a huge list which is
basically compiled with all the
bloomberg news reporters around the
world and we eventually narrow it down
to this and there always are some there
are some there are some quirks there are
a few quirks but but but
not that many where's Europe well Europe
is probably where you would expect it to
be which is the u.s. dominates for the
reasons we've been talking about Europe
it's there there are Europeans on the
list but it's interesting to see who
they are its angular Merkel yeah it's
christine lagarde yeah so they're there
as much for any other reason as Greece
they're there for having manage that
situation Europe is you know Europe it's
not been a great year for Europe that we
do have some Europeans on the list I
mean Anna butene yes Antonia is is on
the list and there are some others
josepho makes the list but not for what
the most obvious reasons no I mean
there's one that maybe fits into your
category of you know sort of cutting
edge in a way we maybe we don't
necessarily think of him that way but he
he is he has he has helped to promote an
industry particularly in London FinTech
that is increasingly important to London
you know as the mainstream bank jobs
fall fintech is rising at quite a high
rate and so he gets credit for he gets
credit for that obviously it's not all
down to him yeah but he gets some credit
for can I come back to to yell and
explore that a little bit more I kind of
include both in the conversation is
yellen's credibility really in question
at the moment certainly in marcus people
are asking lots of questions about the
credibility of the fed will there be
effective in the idea they may even go
back to another round of QE y a far
stretch as that may seem to some whether
the markets would regard that as
credible and whether whether yellen's
therefore credible within the mix but
yeah I mean it's a tough job I think
it's a very difficult job and all fed
governors credibility gets questions at
some stage if they don't hike if they
completely miss the cycle if if alarians
right and they should have raised rates
a year ago yeah I where does that leave
fed credibility with the bond market
well you know I mean but this is a bit
like this sort of vigilantes comment I
mean the point is we live in a
structurally deflationary world so I
I think it I don't think it changes
their credibility dramatically it's just
understanding the world we live in and
and what they have to deal with
basically the world is very indebted
it's not been the u.s. this time it's
more here overseas and the Fed sits at
the center of that and that's the
challenge I think strike you think kind
of influence a credibility go hand in
hand I'm not really do well i think in
what they must be related must you have
to be related but it's it's a fair point
because some credibility is often not
determined until quite a long time after
you act whereas influence could be
determined it could real time yeah it's
very real time and it could be it could
be totally wrong with with Yellen for
example we're really not going to know
are we until down the road quite a bit
as to whether her timing whatever it is
yeah it's good or bad yeah and I would
say if she did raise rates and and
actually that might work against her
credibility because we may find the
markets don't take it very well so so
paradoxically it may be better for a
credibility if she doesn't raise rates
the whole world is geared up for the Fed
raising rates yeah and and okay you can
get your Chilean about this and so you
know what the facts have changed we need
to change our view on this but
nevertheless but ironically the facts
haven't changed the world the point is
people looking at the wrong facts okay
well then I'm much more indebted in the
last in this economic cycle and al its
dollar denominated debt and the world
can't take interest rate hikes it's not
it's just the models are on their way of
thinking about the world is wrong or
it's too narrow is to us focused if the
US was an island you could raise rates
no problem but it's not it's a nap local
economy it's Greenspan's line in 1998
know eventually we've got to take
account of what's happening
internationally and I think that's where
the feds act at the moment